Breaking news. Muhammad never existed.
And once Muslims come to grips with
this, as they're obviously destined to,
Islam will die out. It's just a matter
of time now. If you're not aware, there
are people who are actually making this
argument or variants of it. And in this
video, I'd like to address it
specifically to show how it is by far
one of the absolute weakest arguments
against Islam. One that is destined to
continue having a zero impact on the
Muslim world. All right, let's begin.
Claims against the historicity of
Muhammad are actually much older than
many people think. Elements of it were
being made well over a century ago by
some orientalists in Europe. I
personally was first introduced to
skeptical views of Islam's origins in
the 1990s when I read the 1977 book
Hagarism written by Patricia Cone and I
believe Michael Cook. If I recall, it's
been a while. They did not outright
discount the existence of Muhammad, but
they cast many doubts concerning Islam's
traditional narrative. Since then, an
array of authors and activists have
picked up and amplified this theme,
leading to the grand conclusion that
Muhammad never existed, but was rather
fabricated to give the Arab Empire that
conquered much of North Africa in the
Middle East in the 7th century a
heographical foundation story. The
Umiads, the name that appears to be most
associated with and is spearheading the
argument against Muhammad's existence
nowadays, is J. Smith, Dr. J. Smith. At
least according to the emails I've been
receiving and comments being made here
on this channel, they often go something
like this. We really like what you've
been saying about Islamic history, but
you should stop talking about Muhammad
because he really never existed. Please
see the works of Dr. J. Smith. To be
honest with you, for my first brush with
it as a student in the 1990s, I've never
been much interested in this Muhammad
never existed argument, and we'll get
into why, but I've decided to address it
in this video for two important and
related reasons. first to shed light on
why it is such a weak palemic against
Islam and if anything serves only as a
distraction and two in so doing shedding
light on the subtle and inner workings
of history to look essentially at the
psychological and epistemological
aspects of history why humans believe
what they believe about the past which I
think is fascinating and possibly
instructive for you let's start with me
laying out my personal beliefs
concerning Muhammad whether he existed
or
not I believe in the barebone facts of
his biography I believe that sometimes
In the early 7th century, a man claiming
to be a prophet arose in Arabia and
became dominant through warfare. Why do
I believe this? Because we have several
remarkably early references to his
existence and all by non-Muslims. Let's
begin with arguably the most important
of all these, the doctrinal Jacobe or
Jacobi, which documents a dialogue that
took place on July 13th, 634, a mere 2
years after Muhammad's death. Justice,
one of the participants of this
dialogue, writes that his brother
Abraham, quote, wrote to me saying that
a deceiving prophet appeared amidst the
Sarissens. Sarissens means Arabs.
Justice then says that his brother
Abraham, who was at the time living near
Arabia, referred the matter to an old
Jewish scribe. What do you tell me, Lord
and Teacher, concerning the prophet who
has appeared among the Sarissens?
Abraham asks the elderly gentleman.
And the scribe told me with much
groaning, continues Abraham, "He is
deceiving." This is now the the elderly
gentleman talking. He says, "He is
deceiving, for do prophets come with
swords and chariot. Verily, these events
of today are works of confusion."
Afterwards, Abraham decided to
investigate the matter personally. He
writes, "So I, Abraham, inquired and
heard from those who had met him that
there was no truth to be found in the
so-called prophet, only the shedding of
men's blood." He says also that he has
the keys of paradise which is
incredible. Now Muhammad is first
mentioned by name in a Syriak fragment
also written around 634 again 2 years
after his death. Only scattered phrases
are intelligible. It reads quote many
villages were ravaged by the killing of
Muhammad and many people were slain and
taken prisoner from Galilee to Beth.
Some 10,000 other Christians were
slaughtered in the vicinity of Damascus.
The translators put in brackets to help
make this more intelligible the
following words. So that it reads,
quote, "Many villages in homes were
ravaged by the killing of the followers
of Muhammad, etc." Writing around 640,
Thomas the Presbiter, a Syriak
Christian, also confirms that, quote,
"There was a battle, he's probably
referring to Aaden, between the Romans
and the Arabs of Muhammad in Palestine,
12 miles east of Gaza. The Romans fled.
Some 4,000 poor villagers of Palestine
were killed there. The Arabs ravaged the
whole region. They climbed the mountain
of Mardan and killed many monks there in
the monasteries of Khadar
Binata. The Coptic bishop John of Niku
who was likely alive during the Muslim
conquest of Egypt around 640 641 refers
to Islam as quote the detestable
doctrine of the beast that is Muhammad.
All these quotes I read to you uh come
from these two books and I'm sure
they're in other books but these are the
books that I have in my collection. U
the expansion of the early Islamic State
edited by Fred M. Donner and Seeing
Islam as others saw it a survey and
evaluation of Christian Jewish and
Zerastrian writings on early Islam
by Robert G.
Hyland. Again, these are all very early
and definitive references to Muhammad
and a prophet in Arabia, dating from
between two and eight years from his
death. That is amazingly early by the
standards of history. And I'm not sure,
but would be very curious to learn how
the naysayers who claim Muhammad ever
existed get past such references. If you
know, tell me in the comments. Now, to
underscore just how important the
forementioned references to Muhammad
are, and by way of comparison, keep in
mind that we don't have anything written
as early as between two and eight years
of Christ's lifetime. The earliest
non-Christian references to Christ were
written many decades following his
crucifixion. Josephus about 60 years,
Ply the Younger about 79 years, and
Tacitus 83 years. Again, I find it
amazing that whereas Christians
rightfully cite Joseph's ply and Tacitus
as early proof of Christ's existence,
the references to Muhammad, which
objectively speaking, are even more
compelling, having been written much
closer to their subject's lifetime, 2
years, not 60, are dismissed as
irrelevant by those who would make him a
figment of our
imagination. Okay, there's another very
important reason I believe a Muhammad
figure existed. How else does one
understand the Sunni Shia divide of
history? Think about it. If Muhammad is
a later fabrication meant to give
credibility in a heographical veneer to
the Arab conquerors of the Middle East
and North Africa, the Umiads, how does
one understand the Sunni Shia conflict
which revolves entirely around not just
the existence of a prophet named
Muhammad, but his very DNA? Following
Muhammad's death in 632, two contending
Muslim groups emerged and continue to
exist. Sunnis who represent the majority
and who believe that any qualified
candidate is eligible to becoming
Muhammad's successor or khalif and the
Shia the minority who believe that only
blood descendants of Muhammad could be
his successors particularly through his
daughter Fatima and his first cousin Ali
namely Muhammad's grandsons Hassan and
Hussein and their progeny for centuries
since around 680 Sunnis and Shia have
been killing each other over this point
now let me ask you if there was no
Muhammad then there was no Fatima And if
there was no Fatima, there was no Hassan
and no Hussein. So who are the Shia and
what is their gripe? What event gave
rise to them? Did the Umayad
conspirators who concocted Muhammad also
compelled their own descendants to start
butchering each other? And to what end
exactly? It's again for all these
reasons that as far as I'm concerned,
the barebone facts of Muhammad's
biography that a man claiming to be a
prophet and promising paradise to his
militant followers are by the standards
of history, not to mention common sense,
amply attested. Having said all that, I
do not necessarily believe in those many
details contained in the vast corpus of
Islam scriptures from Hakira or
biography of Muhammad to the countless
volumes of hadith which Muslims believe
contain the detailed doings and
teachings of their prophet. These I
obviously take with a grain of salt,
meaning I have no idea whether they are
true or false and can only judge their
plausibility on an individual basis.
That said, and while we're at it, it's
worth mentioning that the hadith
actually do help verify the existence of
Muhammad, even if indirectly. For those
who don't know, the hadith a hadith in
Arabic plural are vast collections of
what Muhammad reportedly said or did as
passed down orally. Because they were
finally written down between 120 to 250
years following Muhammad's death, those
now raising questions concerning his
existence dismiss them as being too late
and therefore obvious forgeries.
Ironically, however, much of what they
do contain is very unflattering to
Muhammad. Now, if they are fake and
meant to help fabricate a heroic and
noble prophet to validate the Arab
Empire, shouldn't they only contain
information designed to make Muhammad
appear in the best of lights? Instead,
they contain many oddities, putting it
mildly, that have for centuries
challenged the faith of Muslims, not a
few of whom till this very day cite them
as cause for their apostasy from Islam.
Off the top of my head, for example,
there's one canonical hadith, meaning
its authenticity has been confirmed by
the where Muhammad recommends that women
breastfeed strange men as a way of
making them family members whom the
women no longer need cover themselves
around. The Sira also has Muhammad
engaging in deception, ordering the
brutal assassination of old men, mothers
uh for simply mocking him and marrying
the wives of men he had or were killed
on the field of battle. Such accounts
have a ring of truth to them. Not only
because accurate accounts of historical
figures will at least occasionally show
some of their warts. But what we know
about Muhammad from the earliest
sources, a propensity for war,
vengeance, and sexual lentiousness,
further confirm the unflattering
accounts of the S and Hadith. So much
for why I believe a Muhammad figure
existed. In another video, we'll
evaluate the counterarguments against
Muhammad's existence. In the meantime,
let me know what you think in the
comments. What do you make of those very
early non-Muslim references to a false
prophet that I quoted? And how do you
explain the Sunni Shia divide which was
originally about not just Muhammad but
his very DNA?